on a vu que les réseaux de neurones
reposer sur l'exploration de leurs
paramètres guidée par les données en
principe ceux ci pourraient suffire à
créer toutes sortes d'intelligence
artificielle mais en pratique cette
approche pourrait nécessiter des temps
de calcul déraisonnable pour améliorer
les performances d'une machine learning
il est alors pertinent d'ajuster
larchitecture de nos réseaux de neurones
en fonction des données que l'on cherche
à étudier en effet les données que nous
machines sont amenés à étudier sont tout
sauf arbitraire elles contiennent
généralement des symétries naturel il
serait bon d'exploiter notre
connaissance de ces symétrie pour
optimiser l'apprentissage de nos
machines
parmi ces symétrie on trouve les
symétries naturel de translation des
images typiquement un objet reste le
même lorsqu'on se déplace
de gauche à droite mais ça on en reparle
la semaine prochaine pour aujourd'hui
j'aimerais m'attarder davantage sur les
symétries naturel des données
séquentielles c'est à dire des données
qui sont des successions de signaux
élémentaire c'est typiquement le cas du
texte du son d'une vidéo et ce qui est
intéressant avec ces données
séquentielles c'est qu'il est souvent
une forte corrélation locales dans le
temps mais pas nécessairement de fortes
corrélations global je m'explique dans
un texte la lettre q est très souvent
suivi de la lettre u il ya une donc une
très forte corrélation entre la lettre q
et la lettre qui le suit
cependant si je vous demande de deviner
la lettre qu'ils se trouvent
1000 caractères après un q le fait que
vous sachiez qu'il y ait là un cul nour
a sans doute que peu d'influencé sur
votre prédiction
d'ailleurs j'en profite pour recommander
l'excellente vidéo de sciences étonnante
sur les chaînes de markov qui exploite
de telle corrélation locales pour
inventer des mots passible biscornus et
improbable de la langue française
de même comme on l'a vu dans l'épisode
21 lits à world check de google a su
exploiter les propriétés de corrélation
local des mots pour un ferrer une
représentation sémantique des mots et on
déduire des manipulation sémantique
stupéfiante tels que broie - sommes plus
femme est égal à rennes bref nombre de
nos données séquentielles où de telles
propriétés de corrélation locale qu'il
serait bon d'exploiter un sirh bon
modèle pour analyser ces corrélations
devrait faire interférer ces
corrélations locales pour un désir le
sens des mots et des phrases pour
ensuite mieux prédire par exemple des
mots à venir d'où l'idée des réseaux de
neurones récurrents l'idée fondamentale
des réseaux récurrence et d'introduire
dans le réseau de neurones des synapses
qui boucle pour ainsi récupérer
l'information des mots précédent pour
mieux comprendre le mot présent un point
de vue d'architecturé du réseau de
neurones se revient tout bêtement à dire
que les signaux ne vont plus
nécessairement dans un seul sens
certains signaux reviennent vers
l'arrière du réseau de neurones
de façon amusante ce genre de boucles
récurrente est en fait équivalent un
réseau de neurones plus large
en effet en un sens on peut déplier ses
boucles pour voir qu'un réseau récurrent
fait en fait le même calcul care réseaux
fit for words plus grand pour comprendre
cela
prenons le cas du réseau récurrent le
plus simple qui capte les données
extérieures avec un neurone observables
et conclu immédiatement son calcul avec
un neurone de sortie et supposons qu'il
existe une boucle qui renvoie le signal
de sortie vers le neurone de sortie lui
même le premier signal de la données
séquentielles va être lu par le neurone
observable qui va ensuite transmettre
l'information aux neurones de sortie qui
conclut avec une réponse puis le second
signal élu par le neurone observable qui
va transmettre l'information aux
neurones de sortie mais de façon
intéressante ce neurones de sortie va
également prendre en compte la
conclusion du neurone de sortie pour le
premier signal il va donc combiner sa
conclusion pour le premier signal avec
l'information pour le second signal pour
en venir à une conclusion pour le second
signal puis il va combiner cette
conclusion avec l'information qu'il aura
été transmise pour le troisième signal
pour en venir à une conclusion pour le
troisième signal et ainsi de suite
pour y voir plus clair on peut copier
coller le réseau est considéré que
chaque traitement d'informations de
chaque neurone correspond à une version
différente de ceux neurones on voit
ainsi que le premier signal est traitée
par la première version de deux neurones
le deuxième signal est traité par
deuxième version des deux neurones avec
deux façons intrigante une synapse qui
va de la première version du neurone de
sortie vers la seconde version du
neurone de sortie puis le troisième
signal est traité par les troisième
version des neurones avec là encore une
synapse de la seconde version du neurone
de sortie vers sa troisième version
et ainsi de suite
on voit alors qu on obtient un réseau
fit for world c'est à dire un réseau
dont tous les signaux vont de la gauche
vers la droite
tous vos réseaux récurrent est
équivalent à un réseau fit for world
ceci étant dit on peut noter qu'un
réseau récurrents ainsi déplier n'est
pas n'importe quel réseau fit for words
en particulier les neurones les synapses
sont des copies les uns des autres
voilà qui montre qu'à chaque instant ce
sont en fait les mêmes opérations qui
sont utilisés même si ces opérations
s'applique à des signaux différents
voilà qui montre qu'un réseau récurrents
implémente automatiquement une forme de
symétrie de translation à travers le
temps en plus d'exploiter la localité
des corrélations il exploite aussi ainsi
la symétrie par translation des données
séquentielles que l'on retrouve très
souvent dans beaucoup de données
séquentielles
bien sûr j'ai pris là l'exemple d'un
réseau récurrents ultra simple mais de
façon intrigante
il est possible d'avoir des boucles de
récurrence qui remonte plus ou moins
loin dans le passé
ces boucles ont une interprétation
immédiates en termes de mémoire à plus
ou moins long terme
en effet une boucle très courte
correspond à une mémoire à très court
terme
l'information est réutilisé
immédiatement et est potentiellement
immédiatement détruite une boucle à plus
long terme permet de garder
l'information d'un signal en mémoire du
réseau de neurones plus longtemps ce qui
permet d'exploiter des corrélations à
plus long terme
à l'intérieur des données séquentielles
notre conséquence intrigante de tout
cela c'est l' influence cruciale de la
vitesse de lecture
en effet on a su poser ainsi que la
lecture d'un signal prenait autant de
temps qu'une transmission d'informations
à travers une synapse
cependant si on lit les données
séquentielles plus lentement alors on
pourrait lire un signal toutes les deux
transmission synaptique vola qu'il
correspondrait un des pliages différent
du réseau récurrents les ça semble
s'appliquer à nos cerveaux de primates
aussi en pratique quand on lit un texte
on peut le lire plus ou moins vite ce
qui correspond à plus ou moins exploité
les corrélations entre les mots qu'on
lit typiquement si on lit un texte très
vite on pourra y déceler une structure
globale mais les détails des arguments
nous échappe rang al'inverse si on lit
un texte avec beaucoup d'attention
il y un risque de se perdre dans des
arguments locaux et de ne pas voir la
logique globale
texte voilà qui suggère fortement qu'il
est utile de lire et relire un texte à
différentes vitesses et avec différents
niveaux d'attention aux détails ou de
faire de même pour aux hasards une vidéo
samsung
bref tous ces arguments montre que les
réseaux récurrents semble vraiment être
l' architecture naturel pour traiter des
données séquentielles
cependant les réseaux récurrents sont
aussi horriblement dur a entraîné à
cause de l'instabilité des boucles de
récurrence en effet à chaque fois qu'un
signal passe par une boucle il est
multiplié par le poids des synapses qui
traverse
il ya donc un phénomène multiplicatif au
niveau des boucles de récurrence
cependant les phénomènes multiplicatif
répéter donne inéluctablement lieu à des
croissances ou d'aidés croissance
exponentielle si le signal est
constamment x nombre supérieur à 1
alors le signal explosera après quelques
boucles si les x nombre inférieur à 1
alors on observera le phénomène inverse
le signal disparaîtra exponentiellement
vite
ce phénomène est encore plus
problématique au niveau de
l'apprentissage
lorsque l'on applique la rétro
propagation où on a souvent tendance à
observer une disparition des signaux de
rétro propagation on parle alors du
gradient évanescent ou vanishing agent
en anglais pour éviter ce problème
les informaticiens scène rock writer et
jurgen chimiques ou beurs ou introduit
en 1997
l' architecture des longues sorties
memory plus connu sous le nom de l
estime qu'ils possèdent également la
capacité d'effacer tous les signaux de
rétro propagation voilà qui permet
d'éviter de trop longue dépendance entre
différents signaux qui conduirait à des
évanescence des gradients au moment de
l'apprentissage
dit autrement quand il faut apprendre
une longue suite d'arguments il est bon
de séquences et l'apprentissage et
d'apprendre chaque argument de façon
indépendante
ce n'est qu'une fois que chaque argument
sera bien compris que l'on pourra tous
les apprendre tous ensemble typiquement
les lisant vite et en évitant ainsi de
se perdre dans les détails des arguments
me semble ainsi très probable que nous
propre cerveau possède des modules
semblable aux architectural estime en
effet personnellement il m'arrive
souvent d'être interrompus dans un
raisonnement de toutacoup oublier ce que
je pensais avant cette interruption
comme simon module l est
on avait tous supprimés et le fait que l
stm soit encoder par le cerveau humain
suggère qu'il s'agit en effet d'un outil
indispensable pour se confronter à la
grande complexité de données
séquentielles
enfin une dernière remarque amusante et
que pour comprendre des données
séquentielles les données du passé ne
sont généralement pas les seuls à être
utile pour comprendre le présent
surtout quand il s'agit de blagues de
publicité ou de films la fin de la
blague est un publicité ou du film
peuvent être également très utile pour
comprendre le présent
voilà qui a amené barde cosco à
introduire les réseaux dits
bidirectionnelle c'est à dire des
réseaux qui utilise des données futur
pour interpréter le présent et bien sûr
ceci implique que le réseau devra
attendre le futur pour comprendre le
présent
voilà qui semble nécessiter un délai de
compréhension des blagues des publicités
et des films ou à ceux qui te paraît un
délai de compréhension des vidéos cnce
warhol est enfin on a parlé de drop out
on avait déjà fait des liens entre les
réseaux de neurones artificiels et les
réseaux de neurones biologique
on continuera en voit notamment dans les
vidéos à venir puisqu'ils sont
finalement les bonnes idées pour
interpréter les données sensorielles qui
ont été sélectionnés par la nature
semble du coup très performante et du
coup c'est sont une bonne idée que de
haut - s'inspirer de certains de ces
mécanismes naturels pour pouvoir
programmer des intelligences
artificielles et je chausse de saint-yvi
fait la remarque que pour les réseaux de
neurones naturel il ya à la fois des
signaux électriques qui sont envoyées
entre les neurones mais également des
signaux chimiques notamment des
molécules nourault transmettez aux qui
peuvent par exemple faciliter les
signaux ou les réduire en neurones à
l'autre et jose de 7,8 demande du coup
est ce que les informaticiens se sont
inspirés de ça et est ce que c'est
quelque chose a été programmé dans les
antilles ou artificiel aujourd'hui à ma
connaissance il n'y a pas vraiment de
chose qui corresponde vraiment à ça mais
c'est très très très possible que juste
j'ai pas encore tombé sur ce genre
d'article c'est très possible que cela
soit déjà largement explorée mais à ma
connaissance ça ne fait pas ce n'est pas
un ingrédient indispensable en tout cas
d importants d intelligence artificielle
et plus performante d'aujourd'hui donc
encore une fois je me trompe peut-être
et si c'est le cas
dites le dans les commentaires je serai
ravi
de lire un peu plus à ce sujet mais
globalement l'impression que j'ai
aujourd'hui et qui a amené possiblement
à évoluer dans le futur c'est que ses
idées de base des réseaux de neurones
artificiels fondée sur les fonctions de
l'activation et la rétrogradation des
gradients est quelque chose qui me
semblent incroyablement efficace d'un
point de vue purement algorithmique en
tout cas il me semble vraiment que ces
notions de poids synaptique de signaux
qui vont d'un neurone à l'autre et de
fonctions d'activation sont vraiment des
notions fondamentales ainsi que la rétro
propagation
j'ai points sans aujourd'hui du mal à
voir des alternatives crédibles à cela
pour entraîner des réseaux ou des
modèles de façon très générale de très
très très grande complexité comme les
réseaux de drones avec des millions ou
des milliards de paramètres j'ai
l'impression aujourd'hui que ça c'est
vraiment l'ingrédient de base
après il ya plein d'ingrédients à mettre
par dessus et peut-être qu'il ya
d'autres paramètres sur lesquels on peut
jouer smooth d'hyper paramètres sur
lesquels on peut jouer comme par exemple
il ya une discussion ce très récurrente
sur les appels des learning waits c'est
à dire une direction de gradient mais à
quel point on suit cette direction de
gradient est ce qu'on fait un pas de
gradient ou 6 où est-ce qu'on peut se
permettre de faire sans pas du gradient
tout à coup donc ça ça correspond
vraiment à la question du learning wake
est peut-être que variés le learning
wright au cours de l'apprentissage
notamment peut-être avoir tu entends des
sceaux brusque du lord ingrid qui
augmente ça pourrait correspondre à
avoir des espèces de neurotransmetteurs
qui tout à coup facilite la transmission
de signaux très spéculatif ce que je dis
est sans doute qu'il faut beaucoup plus
de recherches à ce sujet wen date de
demande quelle est la probabilité selon
moi qu'il existerait un mur technologie
qui empêcherait les intelligences
artificielles d'aujourd'hui d'atteindre
le niveau humain et de surpasser
alors c'est si tu vois un peu compliqué
cette question parce que j'aime est très
clair ce qu'on entend par les ja
d'aujourd'hui sont plein d'améliorations
au niveau des architectures plein de
petites astuces comme ça à m on va
parler aussi dans de futurs épisodes de
mettre plusieurs modules les uns après
les autres des réseaux qui avaient des
feedbacks un terreau midi
bref il ya beaucoup de progrès dans ce
genre à faire peut-être même combinez
cela avec d'autres idées algorithmique
comme je sais pas moi-même cmc ou
monte-carlo frissen pour dans lequel
trois un peu dingo il ya plein de
combinaisons possibles
est-ce que ça appelle ça de
l'intelligence artificielle
d'aujourd'hui ou pas ma réponse bien sûr
à cette question dépend de ce qu'on
entend par quelles sont les technologies
d'intelligence artificielle
d'aujourd'hui mais globalement je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on a déjà quand même fait
pas mal le tour de pas mal des
techniques fondamentales de base en tout
cas de l'intelligence artificielle et
j'aurais tendance à pareille qu'il n'y
aura pas tout cas besoin de de
révolution conceptuelle majeurs que sont
plus des réflexions sur l'architecturé
des réseaux de neurones comment publier
plusieurs choses pour que ça se passe
bien - est-ce qu'on peut exploiter au
mieux les données et est la
rétrogradation des réseaux de neurones
pour faire de meilleures impressions de
la forme lebesque quelle fonction
d'activation utilisez plutôt que quelle
autre est-ce qu'il faut pas réduire la
connectivité des oiseaux neurones et
surtout l'impression que j'ai celle que
pour que nos réseaux de neurones
d'aujourd'hui progressent beaucoup plus
il faut surtout qu'ils grossissent en
taille et en profondeur j'envoie
notamment l'argument de turing nom
apparaît dans l'épisode 7 sur la taille
nécessaire des réseaux de neurones pour
atteindre le niveau humain moi j'aurais
tendance à parier avec ses fortes
crédence que tout ça ça suffira pour
atteindre une audience artificielle de
niveau il faut simplement bien combiner
tous les différentes idées que l'on a
aujourd'hui et faire des algorithmes de
plus en plus gros qui analyse de plus en
plus de données pour y parvenir à la
question un petit peu floue du coup
c'est un peu difficile de progresser
d'être assez confiant notamment sur
l'importance de dessins de grignan
stochastiques
donc je mettrais quelque chose comme 95%
mais encore une fois ça dépend de ce
qu'on entend par la question qui était
posée
ensuite notre question qu'on peut se
poser c'est quelle est la probabilité ou
moins lié un mur technologique entre
l'intelligence artificielle et
l'intelligence humaine et là par contre
la probabilité qu'il existe un mur
technologique nous semble vraiment
vraiment épisode la questionne de très
faible activité ou un jeu mettra
peut-être ypsilon de l'ordre
1 sur 10 puissance 20 disques ans 30
tiennent vraiment vraiment très très
très très faible pourquoi parce que j'en
parle notamment dans mon livre sur la
formule de bise
il semble que l'intelligence correspond
essentiellement à calculer les
probabilités de bisous des
approximations de la forme de belize et
optimiser les prises de décisions pour
maximiser les conséquences en fonction
de notre fonction d'objectifs et si on
croit en ce formalisme qui me semble
vraiment très très très loin quand j'en
parle très longuement dans mon livre
l'intelligence ne s'agirait vraiment que
de calculs et à ce moment là s'il ne
s'agit que de calculs j'ai bien peur que
les technologies sont capables de faire
des calculs plus efficace plus
performants que nous peut-être pas
aujourd'hui mais dans le futur au fur à
mesure qu'il y a ce progrès
technologique et surtout si on se dirige
vers du hardware spécialisé pour les
calculs de descendre de gradient ce gaz
est typiquement dans des réseaux de
neurones par l'elysée tout ce qu'il faut
là j'ai bien l'impression que les
performances calculatoire des machines
seront largement supérieur au nôtre
si c'est le cas et ça me paraît très
très très très probable que ce sera le
cas il me semble très très très
improbable qu'il y ait un mur
technologique entre l'intelligence des
machines et l'intelligence humaine et
j'espère que j'avais aimé cette vidéo la
projection on va parler de l'autre
grande architecture des réseaux de
neurones qui est très très utilisés à
savoir les réseaux de convulsions si
vous avez aimé cet épisode dont celle de
l'ikea leconte et à les partager et
j'espère que vous serez là
[Musique]